my name is mariana ignatesco i work in
one of the two legal units of digit
trade i'm a case handler oh much better
[Music]
my name is colton brown i'm the head of
unit of one of the two legal units of dg
trade
my name is martin lucas i'm the head of
the legal affairs unit in digit trade
[Music]
the european commission has launched a
new complaint system for reporting
market access barriers and breaches of
trade and sustainable development
commitments in the eu trade agreement
the single entry point
was launched
in
2020 so the commission launched a single
entry point and what is the single entry
point the single entry point is there
for companies when they face issues with
market access in third country markets
so we have systems in place to deal with
those market access barriers it's a
one-stop shop
for
companies from the eu but also business
association or civil society or even any
citizen to launch a complaint and why
would a complaint be launched so either
a complaint is launched because there is
a market access issue so there is a
barrier either behind the border or at
the border
or um that there is a problem an
infringement of what we call the trade
and system development provisions
so the binding rules that we negotiate
on labor environment climate and many
other issues and then obviously if
things go really wrong then we may
consider also to launch what we call the
desperate settlement
[Music]
the eu stands for
rules-based
trade
and rules are only as good as their
enforcement
dispute settlement
is basically holding everyone to what
they have committed to
it's about trust in relations
dispute settlement should not be seen as
a hostile act
it is actually a tool that keeps
everyone honest dispute settlement is
a legal process
where
states can resolve the differences now
the most important dispute settlement
framework is in the world trade
organization the wto
where the eu is one of the main users of
dispute settlement
but we also have
those procedures in our free trade
agreements
and they are being used more and more in
our free trade agreements we have
what
i think it makes sense of what we call a
fork in the road clause
so you go down one way you can't come
back so you either choose the wto or you
choose the free trade agreement you
can't do both at the same time and the
way we look at this is we analyze what
are the obligations that we're having
that we think the third country is not
respecting and that we want to to to
push and so what really drives the issue
is are there additional commitments that
we've negotiated
that are not being respected that we
want to to pursue
via a bilateral dispute and if you look
at the examples of the cases that we've
taken most of them not all of them but
most of them are
the bilateral disputes are ones that we
could only have taken under
the bilateral free trade agreement so
the korea case there are no labour
commitments
in the world trade organization so we
couldn't have brought the case
[Music]
the first step is to gather
information so to gather the relevant
legislation to
gather information on the economic
impact and other considerations a big
part of the work is translation of the
documents because it's usually disputes
against third countries and you need to
translate those documents from
those languages after that we
start working on a legal analysis we
look into what possible
legal provisions of either the
bilateral agreement or wto agreements
are are being infringed and then
we also discuss with member states and
we explain the problem and what we
intend to do
and after all the the green lights we
uh launch
the dispute
when we look at the record of of the
cases that we have we have brought we
have a very high success rate
of winning our offensive
offensive cases
and we very rarely need to resort to the
very final enforcement
tool that we have and that is to impose
trade sanctions
[Music]
we make a difference when
we bring about change on the ground
yeah
um
the korea example career ratified three
of the four we still work in the fourth
one but ratified three of the four
international labor organization
conventions that amended its trade union
act most rewarding is
talking to the companies
trying to understand the problem that
they are having and at the end you know
launching a dispute uh to address that
problem
and of course when you get a
you know a positive result uh a panel
report in your favor
you feel like you've made a difference
when you can see whether whether it be
trade unions or whether it is people who
export goods
export services when you see that they
have a problem resolved
you can you can go home happy you've
done your job
[Music]